morning and welcome back so what we'll
see today in class is the first in-depth
discussion of a learning algorithm
linear regression and in particular over
the next one hour and a bit you see a
linear regression batch and Tsukasa
Granderson's is an algorithm for fitting
linear aggression models and then the
normal equations as a way of is a very
efficient way to let you fit linear
models and we're going to define
notation and a few concepts today that
will lay the foundation for a lot of the
work that we'll see the rest of this
quarter so to motivate linear regression
scofield maybe the may be the simplest
one of the simplest learning algorithms
you remember the Alvin video the
autonomous driving video that I had
shown in class on Monday for the
self-driving car video that was a
supervised learning problem and this
term supervised learning meant that you
were given access which was a picture of
what's in front of the car and the
algorithm had to map that to an output Y
which was the steering direction and
that was a regression problem because
the output Y that you want is continuous
value right as opposed to a
classification problem where Y is the
speed and we'll talk about
classification next Monday but
supervised learning regression so I
think the simplest maybe the simplest
possible learning algorithm a supervised
learning regression problem is linear
regression and to motivate that rather
than using a saw driving car example you
know which is quite complicated it will
build up a supervised learning algorithm
using a simpler example so let's say you
want to predict or what estimate prices
of houses so the way you'd build a
learning algorithm is start by
collecting a data set of houses and
their prices so this is a data set that
we collected off Craigslist a little bit
back this is data from Portland Oregon
but so there's a size of house in square
feet and that's the price of a house in
thousands of dollars right so there's a
house that is a 2100 full square feet
who's asking price was $400,000 pulse
with that size with that price and so on
okay and maybe more conventionally if
you plot this data with there's the size
that's the price see some data set like
that and what would end up doing today
is fit a straight line to this data I
didn't go through how to do that so in
supervised learning um the process of
supervised learning is that you have our
training set such as the data set that I
drew on the left and you feed this to
learning algorithm and the job of the
learning algorithm is to output a
function to make predictions about
housing prices and by convention I'm
gonna call this function that it outputs
a hypothesis and a job with the
hypothesis is you know it will it can
input the size of a new house the size
of a different house that you haven't
seen yet and will output the estimated
price okay so the job of the learning
algorithm is to input a training set and
out for the hypothesis the job with
hypothesis is to take as input any size
of a house and try to tell you what if
things should be the price of that house
now when designing a learning algorithm
and and you know even though linear
regression right you may have seen it in
a linear algebra class before in some
class before the way you go about
structuring a machine learning algorithm
is important and design choices of you
know what is the workflow what does the
data say what is the hypothesis
represents a hypothesis these are the
key decisions you have to make in pretty
much every supervised learning every
machine learning algorithms design so as
we go through the new regression I'll
try to describe the concepts clearly as
well because they'll lay the foundation
for the rest of the algorithms sometimes
much more completely I'll go as you see
later this quarter so when designing a
learning algorithm the first thing we'll
need to ask is um how do you represent
the hypothesis and in linear regression
the for the purpose of this lecture
we're going to say that the hypothesis
is going to be input size X and output a
number as a as a linear function of the
size X okay and then the mathematicians
in the room you say technique doesn't
have fine function it was a linear
function there's no theta zero
technically you know they've been in
machine learning is sometimes just
causes a linear function but technically
is an affine function it does it doesn't
matter so more generally in this example
we have just one input feature X more
generally if you have multiple input
features so if you have more data more
information about these houses such as
number of bedrooms excuse me mom
handwriting's okay that's the word
bedrooms then I guess my father-in-law
lives a little bit outside Portland and
he's actually really into real estate so
this is that your real data set in
Portland so more generally if you know
the size as was the number of bedrooms
in these houses then you may have a two
input features where x1 is the size and
x2 is the number of bedrooms I'm using
the pound sign bedrooms to denote number
of bedrooms and you might say that you
estimate the size of a house as H of X
equals theta 0 or Stata 1x
1 plus theta 2 x2 where x1 is the size
of the house and x2 is is the number of
bedrooms okay so in order to
so in order to simplify the notation in
order to make that notation a little bit
more compact I'm also going to introduce
this other notation where we want to
write the hypothesis as sum from J
equals 0 to 2 of theta J XJ so the
summation where for conciseness we
define X 0 to be equal to 1 ok see we
define if you define X 0 to be a dummy
feature that always takes on the value
of 1 then you can write the hypothesis H
of X this way sum from J equals 0 to 2
or just theta J XJ
it's the same with that equation that
you saw to the upper right and so here
theta becomes a three dimensional
parameter theta 0 theta 1 theta 2 this
index starting from 0 and the features
become a 3 dimensional feature vector X
0 X 1 X 2 where X 0 is always 1 X 1 is
the size of the house and X 2 is the
number of bedrooms of the house so to
introduce a bit more terminology theta
is called the parameters of the learning
algorithm and the job of the learning
algorithm is to choose parameters theta
that allows you to make good predictions
about your prices of houses right and
just to lay out some more notation that
we're going to use throughout this
quarter I'm going to use a standard that
M will define as the number of training
examples so M is going to be the number
of rows
right in the table above where you know
each house you have your training said
just one training example you've already
seen me use X to denote the inputs and
often the inputs
I'll call features you know I think as a
as an emerging discipline grows up right
notation kind of emerges depending on
what different scientists use for the
first time when you write a paper so I
think that you know I think that the
fact that we call these things
hypotheses frankly I don't think that's
a great name but but I think someone
many decades ago wrote a few papers
calling a hypothesis and then others
follow and we kind of stuck with some of
this terminology but X is what's called
input features a sentence input
attributes and Y is the output right and
sometimes we call this a target variable
and so X comma Y is one training example
and I'm going to use this notation X
superscript I comma Y superscript I in
parentheses to denote the training
example okay so the superscript
parentheses I that's not exponentiation
I think that as we build this is this
notation X I comma Y I this is just a
way of writing an index into the table
of training examples above so so maybe
for example if the first training
example is the size house of science to
104 so X 1 1 would be equal to 2104
right because this is the size of the
first house in the training example
and I guess X the second example feature
one would be one four one six with our
example though so the super strip in
parentheses is just some it's just the
index into the different training
examples where I superscript I here
we're running from one through m1
through the number of training examples
you have and then one last bit of
notation I'm going to use n to denote
the number of features you have for the
supervised learning problem so in this
example n is equal to 2 right because we
have two features which is the size the
house and the number of bedrooms so two
features which is why you can take this
write and write this as a sum from J
equals 0 to n and so here X and theta
are n plus 1 dimensional because we
added the extra X 0 and theta 0 ok so so
if you have two features then these are
three dimensional vectors and more
generally if you have n features you end
up with X and theta being n plus 1
dimensional features all right and you
know you see this notation multiple
times in multiple algorithms throughout
this quarter so if you you know don't
manage to memorize all these symbols
right now don't worry about it you see
them over and over and over come
familiar alright so um given the data
set and given that this is the way you
define the hypothesis how do you choose
the parameters right so you're the
learning algorithms job is to choose
values for parameters theta so that it
can output hypotheses so how do you
choose parameters theta well what we'll
do is let's choose theta
such that H of X is close to Y for the
training examples so and I think the
final bit of notation I've been writing
H of X as a function of the features of
the house as a function of the size and
number of bedrooms the house sometimes
to emphasize that H depends both on the
parameters theta and on the input
features X I'm going to use H subscript
theta X to emphasize that the hypothesis
depends both on the parameters and on
the you know input features X right but
sometimes for notational convenience I
just write this as H of X sometimes I
include the theta there and they mean
the same thing it's just maybe a
abbreviation in notation but so in order
to learn set of parameters what we'll
want to do is choose a parameters theta
so that at least for the houses whose
prices you know that you know the
learning algorithm outputs prices that
are close to what you know were the
correct prices for that set of houses
with their compare asking prices for
those houses and so more formally in the
linear regression algorithm also called
ordinary least-squares with a linear
regression we will want to minimize I'm
going to build out this equation one
piece of the time okay minimize the
squared difference between what the
hypothesis outputs H subscript theta of
X minus y squared right so let's say we
want to minimize the squared difference
between the prediction which is H of x
and y which is a correct price and so
what we want to do is
choose values of theta that minimizes
that to fill this out you know you have
M training examples so I'm going to sum
from I equals 1 through m of that
squared difference so this is sum over I
equals 1 through all say 50 examples you
have right the squared difference
between what your algorithm predicts and
what the true price of the house is and
then finally by convention we put up
one-half there it's put a 1/2 constant
there because when we take derivatives
to minimize this later
putting 1/2 there will make some of the
math a little bit simpler so you know
changing 1 adding a 1/2 minimizing that
formula should give you the same ran
says minimize a 1/2 of that but we often
put a 1/2 there since I make the math a
little bit simpler later ok
and so in linear regression I'm gonna
define the cost function J of theta to
be equal to that and we'll find
parameters theta that minimizes the cost
function J of theta ok and questions
often gotten is you know why squared
error why not absolute error or this
error to the power of 4 we'll talk more
about that when we talk about when we
talk about a generalization of linear
regression when we talk about
generalized linear models we should do
next week you see that linear regression
is a special case of a bigger family of
algorithms called generalizing the
models and using squared error
corresponds to a Gaussian but justified
may be a little bit more Y squared error
rather than absolute error or error to
the power 4 next week so um let me just
check see if any questions
okay cool alright so um so let's Knicks
let's see how you can implement an
algorithm to find a value of theta that
minimizes J of theta that minimizes the
cost function J of theta we're going to
use an algorithm called gradient descent
and you know there's our first loss
seeking this Austrian so trying to
figure out what just takes like this all
right and so with gradient descent we
are going to start with some value of
theta and it could be you know theta
equals the vector of all zeros would be
a reasonable default we could initialize
a random you can't doesn't really matter
but theta is this three dimensional
vector and I'm writing zero with an
arrow on top to denote the vector of all
zero so zero with an arrow on top does
it vector there's a zero zero zero
everywhere right so so stop to some you
know initial value of theta and we're
going to keep changing theta to reduce J
of theta okay so let me show you a
but let me show you a visualization of
gradient descent and and it will write
all the math
so alright let's say you want to
minimize some function J of theta and is
importantly get the axis right in this
diagram right so in this diagram the
horizontal axes are theta 0 and theta 1
and what you want to do is find values
for theta 0 and theta 1 in our in our
examples as you say the zero theta 1
theta 2 cos theta 3 dimentional I can't
plot that so I'm just using theta 0 and
theta 1 but what you want to do is find
values for theta 0 and theta 1 right
that's the right you want to find values
of theta zero and theta one that
minimizes the height to the surface J of
theta so maybe this this looks like a
pretty good point
or something okay and so in green
descent you you know start off at some
point on this surface and you do that by
initializing theta 0 and theta 1 either
randomly or to the value of all zeros or
something doesn't doesn't matter too
much and what you do is imagine you are
standing on this little hill right
standing at the point at that little
extra that little cross what you're
doing great in the sentence is turn on
turn around
all 360 degrees and look around you and
see if you were to take a tiny little
step you know take a tiny little baby
set in what direction should you take a
little step to go downhill as fast as
possible because you're trying to go
downhill which is go to the lowest
possible elevation go to the lowest
possible point of J of theta so what
you're in descent will do is a stand at
that point look around look all around
you and say well what direction should I
take a little step in to go down so as
quickly as possible because you want to
minimize J of theta you want to reduce
the value of J of theta you want to go
to the lowest possible elevation on this
pillow and so Grint descent will take
that little baby step right and then and
then repeat now you're a little bit
lower on the surface so you can take a
look all around you and say oh looks
like that he'll let that little
direction this
cheapest direction of the steepest
gradient downhill so you take another
little step take another set another
step and so on until until you until you
get to a whole via local optima now one
property or green descent is that um
depending where you initialize
parameters you can't get to local
different points right so previously we
had started it at that little point X
but imagine if you had started it you
know just a few steps over to the right
right that new axis of the one on the
Left if you are on green descent from
that new point then that wouldn't be the
first step there on the second step and
so on and you would have gotten to a
different local optimum your different
level okay it turns out that when you
run gradient descent on linear
regression it turns out that there will
not be local optimum the world we'll
talk about that a little bit okay so
let's formalize D
gradient descent algorithm
[Music]
in gradient descent each step of
gradient descent is implemented as
follows so so remember in this example
the training set is fixed right you you
know you've collected the data set of
housing prices from Portland Oregon so
you just have to add so in your computer
memory and so the data centers takes the
cost function J is a fixed function this
function parameters theta and the only
thing you're gonna do is tweak or modify
the parameters theta one step of
gradient descent it can be implemented
as follows or just say that J gets
updated as say that J - I'll just write
this out so bit more notation I'm gonna
use : equals and let me use this
notation to denote assignment so what
this means is we're going to take the
value on the right and assign it to
theta on the left right and so so in
other words in the notation will use
this quarter you know a colon equals a
plus one this means increment the value
of a by one whereas you know a equals B
if I write a equals B I'm asserting a
statement of fact I'm searching that the
value of a is equal to the value of B
and hopefully I won't ever write a
equals a plus one right because because
that is really true alright so in each
step of gradient descent you're going to
for each value of J so you're gonna do
this for J equals 0 1 2 or 0 1 up to n
where n is the number of features for
each value of J takes a DJ and update it
according to theta J minus alpha which
is called the learning rate
alpha the learning rate times this
formula and this formula is the partial
derivative of the cost function J of
theta with respect to the parameter
theta J okay and then this is partial
derivative notation for those of you
that I know haven't seen calculus for a
while or haven't seen you know some of
their prerequisite or a while we'll go
over some more of this in a little bit
greater detail in discussion section but
I'll do this
quickly now
but I know if you take a look calculus
class a while back you may remember that
the derivative of a function is you know
defines the direction of steepest
descent so it defines the direction that
allows you to go downhill as steeply as
possible on the hill and dance question
oh how do you determine learning rate
let me get back to that it's a good
question for now you know there's a
theory there's a practice in practice
you said to 0.01 let me say a bit more
about that later if you actually if you
scale all the features between zero and
one you know minus one and plus one or
something like that and then try you
could try a few values and see what lets
you minimize the function best but if
the features are scale to plus minus one
I usually start with 0.01 and try
increasing and diffusing it say say a
little more about it all right cool so
um let's see I'm just quickly show how
the derivative calculation is done and
you know I'm gonna do a few more
equations in this lecture and then and
then over time I think all of this all
of these definitions and derivations are
written out in full detail in the
lecture notes posted on the course
website so sometimes I'll do more math
in class when we want you to see the
steps of the derivation and sometimes
the save time and cost will gloss over
the mathematical details that leave you
the read over the full details in the
lecture notes under sisters you know
course website so partially whatever
strategy of theta that's the partial er
of respect to that 1/2 H of theta of X
minus y squared and so I'm gonna do a
slightly simpler version assuming we
have just one training example right the
actual derivate definition of J of theta
has a sum over I from 1 to M over all
the training examples so I'm just
forgetting that some for now so if you
have only one training example
and so from calculus if you take the
derivative of a square you know the two
comes down and so that cancels out with
the hall so two times one half times the
thing inside right and then by the chain
rule of derivatives that's times the
partial derivative of theta J minus y so
if you take the derivative of a square
the two comes down and then you take the
derivative of what's inside and multiply
that right and so the 200 one half
cancel out so this leaves you with minus
y times partial derivative respect to
theta J of say the zero X zero plus
theta 1 x1 plus dot plus theta n X and
minus y I where I just took the
definition of H of X and expanded it out
to that to that sum right because H of X
is just equal to that so if you look at
the partial derivative of each of these
terms with respect to theta J the
partial derivative of every one of these
terms respect to theta J is going to be
0 except for the term corresponding to J
because you know if if J was equal to
one say right then this term doesn't
depend on theta 1 this term this term
all of them do not even depend on theta
1 the only term that depends on theta 1
is this term over there and the partial
derivative of this term respect to theta
1 would be just X 1 and so when you take
the partial derivative of this big some
with respect to say the J intercept just
J equals 1 and respect to theta J in
general then the only term that even
depends on theta J is the term theta J
XJ
and so the partial derivative of all the
other terms end up being zero and
partial observer this term respect to
theta J it is equal to XJ okay and so
this ends up being a theta X minus y
times XJ okay and again if you haven't
you haven't played with calculus for a
while if you you know don't quite
remember what positive is or don't quite
get what I just said don't worry too
much about it go over a bit more in
section and we and then also read
through the lecture notes which kind of
goes over this in in in more detail and
more slowly than then we might do in
class
so um so plugging this let's see so
we've just calculated that this partial
derivative is equal to this and so
plugging it back into that formula one
step of gradient descent is is the
following which is that we will let
theta J be updated according to u theta
J minus the learning rate and times H of
X minus y times X change ok now I'm
gonna just add a few more things to this
equation so I did this for one training
example but this was I kind of used
definition of the cost function J of
theta defined using just one single
training example but you actually have M
training examples and so the the correct
formula for the derivative is actually
if you take this thing and sum it over
all M training examples the derivative
of the derivative sum is the sum of the
derivatives right so so you actually if
you redo this derivation you know
summing with the correct definition of J
of theta which sums over all M training
examples if you just redo that the
derivation you end up with some equals I
threw em that right where remember X I
is the I've training examples input
features y I is the target Abel is the
price in the life training example and
so this is the actual correct formula
for the partial derivative respect to
that the cost function J of theta when
it's defined using all of the what is
defined using all of the training
examples
and so the gradient descent algorithm is
to repeat until convergence carry out
this update and in each iteration of
gradient descent you do this update
before J equals 0 1 up to n where n is
the number of features so n was 2 in our
example ok and if you do this then you
know then what will happen is show you
the animation yes you fit hopefully you
find a pretty good value of the
parameters theta so it turns out that
when you plot the cost function J of
theta for a linear regression model it
turns out that unlike the earlier
diagram I have shown which has local
Optima it turns out that if J of theta
is defined a way that you know we just
defined it for linear regression there's
this sum of squared terms then J of
theta turns out to be a quadratic
function where it's the sum of these
squares of terms and so J of theta will
always look like look like a big bowl
like this another way to look at this oh
and so and so J of theta does not have
local Optima or the only local Optima is
also the global optimum the other way to
look at the function like this is to
look at the contours of this plot right
so you pull the contours by looking at
the big bowl and taking horizontal
slices and plotting where they're where
the curves where where the edges of the
horizontal slices so the contours of a
big bowl or I guess a formal is a bigger
and of this quadratic function will be
ellipses like these or these ovals or
these ellipses like this and so if you
run gradient descent on this algorithm
let's say I initialize
my parameters at that little X shown
over here and usually you initialize say
to the ruler zero but but you know but
it doesn't matter too much so let's to
initialize over there then with one step
of gradient descent the algorithm will
take that step downhill and then where
the second step will take that step
downhill oh and by the way fun fact if
you if you think about the contours of a
function it turns out that the direction
of steepest descent is always at ninety
degrees is always orthogonal to the
contour direction right so no seem to
remember that file my high school
something I think it's alright and so as
you as you take steps downhill because
there's only one global minimum this
algorithm will eventually converge to
the and so the question just now about
the choice of the learning rate alpha if
you set alpha to be very very large to
be too large then it can overshoot right
the steps you take can be too large and
you can run past the minimum if you said
to be too small then you need a lot of
iterations and yah will be slow and so
what happens in practice is usually you
try a few values and and and see what
value of the learning rate allows you to
most efficiently you know drive down the
value of J of theta and if you see J of
theta increasing rather than decreasing
you see the cost function increasing
rather than decreasing then there's a
very strong sign that the learning rate
is too large and so actually what I
often do is actually try out multiple
values of the learning rate alpha and
and and and usually try them on
exponential scale so try 0.01 0.02 to
0.04 0.08 kind of a doubling scale or
doubling scale or tripling scale and try
a few values and see what value allows
you to drive down the learning rate
that's this I'm just
so I just want to visualize this in one
other way which is with the data so this
is this is the actual dataset there
they're actually 49 points in the
dataset so M the number of training
examples is 49 and so if you initialize
the parameters to 0 that means
initializing your hypothesis or
initializing your straight line fit to
the data to be that horizontal line
right so if you initialize theta 0
equals 0 theta 1 equals 0 then your
hypothesis is you know for any input
size of house of a price the estimated
price is 0 and so your hypothesis starts
off with a horizontal line there just
whatever the input X the output Y is 0
and what you're doing as you run
gradient descent is you're changing the
parameters theta right so the parameters
went from this value to this value to
this value to this value and so on and
so the other way of visualizing gradient
descent is if gradient descent starts
off with this hypothesis with each
iteration of gradient descent you are
trying to find different values of the
parameters theta that allows the
straight line to fit the data better so
after one iteration of gradient descent
this is the new hypothesis you now have
different values of theta zero and theta
one that fits the gate a little bit
better after two iterations you end up
with that hypothesis and with each
iteration of grading descent is trying
to minimize J of theta is trying to
minimize one half of the sum of squares
errors of the hypothesis or predictions
on the different examples right well
three iterations of green descent for
their Asians and so on and then and then
the bunch more durations and eventually
converges to that hypothesis which is
pretty pretty decent straight line fit
to the data ok so question
oh sure me just repeat question why is
the y-you subtracting alpha times the
gradient rather than adding alpha times
the gradient um let me suggest let me
raise the screen so let me suggest you
work through one example it turns out
that if you add a multiple times the
gradient you'll be going uphill rather
than going down low and maybe one way to
see that would be um you know take a
quadratic function right if you're here
the gradient is a positive direction and
you want to reduce so this would be
theta and just me jr. yes so you want
thither to decrease so the green is
positive you want to decrease say there
is you want to subtract in multiple
times a gradient
um I think maybe the best way to see
that would be to work through an example
yourself said J of theta equals theta
squared and sin theta equals one so here
at the quadratic function the differs is
equal to one so you want to subtract the
value from say a rotten egg all right
great so you've now seen your first
learning algorithm and you know green
descent and linear aggression is
Daphne's still one of the most widely
used learning algorithms in the world
today and if you implement this review
if you implement this today right you
could use this but some actually pretty
pretty decent purposes right now I want
to give this algorithm one other name
so our gradient descent algorithm here
calculates this derivative by summing
over your entire training set M and so
sometimes this version of gradient
descent
has another name which is Bosch gradient
descent and the term batch you know and
again I think a machine learning a whole
committee we just make up names of stuff
and sometimes the names aren't great but
the the term Bactrian descent refers to
that you look at the entire training set
all 49 examples in the example I just
had on PowerPoint you know you think of
all 49 examples it's one batch of data
and we're gonna process all the data as
a batch so hence the name batch gradient
descent
do you disadvantage a bachelor in
descent is that if you have a giant data
set if you have and and you're in era of
big data we're really moving to large
and larger data set there and serve use
you know train machine learning models
of like hundreds of millions of examples
and and if you are trying to if you have
if you download the US Census database
if your data on the United States Census
that's a very large data set and you
want to predict housing prices from
across the United States that that that
may have a data set with many many
millions of examples and the
disadvantage a batch gradient descent is
that in order to make one update to your
parameters in order to take even a
single step of gradient descent you need
to calculate this sum and if M is say a
million or ten million or 100 million
you need to scan through your entire
database scan your entire dataset and
calculate this for you know 100 million
examples and sum it up and so every
single step of gradient descent becomes
very slow because you're scanning over
you're reading over right like 100
million training examples and before you
can even you know make one tiny little
step of gradient descent okay by the way
I think I don't know I feel like in
today's ever a big day there people
start to lose intuitions about what's
the baby that's and I think even by
today's standards like a hundred many
examples is still very big
I rarely only rarely use dungeon
examples although maybe in a few years
we'll look back on Hydra examples and
say that was really small but at least
today so the main disadvantage of
battery and descends is every single
step of your in descent requires that
you read through you know your entire
data set may be terabytes of data sets
maybe maybe maybe tens of hundreds of
terabytes of data before you can even
update the parameters just once
and if gradient descent needs you know
hundreds of iterations to converge then
you be scanning through your entire data
set hundreds of times oh and sometimes
we train our algorithms so thousands of
tens of thousands of iterations and so
so this this gets expensive so there's
an alternative to bash gradient descent
and let me just write out the algorithm
here then we can talk about it which is
going to repeatedly do this
so this algorithm which is called
stochastic gradient descent instead of
scanning through all million examples
before you update the parameters theta
even a little bit in stochastic grain
descent instead in the inner loop of the
algorithm you loop through J equals 1
through m of ticking a gradient descent
step using the derivative of just one
single example of just that one example
oh excuse me I write so let I go from 1
to M and update theta J for every J so
you update this for J equals 1 through n
update theta J using this derivative but
now this derivative is taken just with
respect to one training example the
example I just I guess you update this
for every J and so let me just draw a
picture of what this algorithm is doing
if this is the contour like the one you
saw just now so the axes are theta 0 and
theta 1 and the height of the surface
right to know the contours J of theta
with stochastic render sense what you do
is you initialize the parameters
somewhere and then you will look at your
first training example hey let's just
look at one house and see if we can
predict that houses better and you
modify the parameters to increase the
accuracy where you predict the price of
that one house and because you for the
innovator just the one house you know
maybe you end up improving the
parameters a little bit but not quite
going in the most direct direction
downhill and you're going look at the
second house and say hey let's try to
fit that house better and then update
the parameters and look at third house a
house
and so as you run so costly gradient
descent it takes a slightly noisy
slightly random path but on average is
headed to what the global minimum okay
so as you run stochastic current descent
so her great in the sense will actually
never quite converge in backstreet
understand it kind of went to the global
minimum and stopped right but so
classroom in this end even as you won't
run it the parameters oscillate and
won't ever quite converge because you're
always running around looking at
different houses and trying to do better
on just that one hold on that one house
on that one house but when you have a
very large data set stochastic gradient
descent allows your implementation
allows you algorithm to make much faster
progress and so and and so when you have
very large data sets the casa grande
descent is use much more practice than -
brilliant
you know is it possible stop so
customers and and it's such over the
battery understand yes it is so boy
something wasn't a tough one in this
class solvency a suitor these mini
battery in the sense where you don't
when you use say 100 examples this time
rather than one example of the time and
so that's another algorithm that I
should use more often in practice I
think people rarely actually so in
practice you know when your data set is
large we rarely ever switch to batch
gradient descent because battery in the
sin is just so slow right so I don't
know I'm thinking through concrete
examples of problems that worked on and
I think that what may actually may I
think that dump right for a lot of for
modern machine learning where you have
if you have very very large datasets
right so you know whatever if you're
building a speech recognition system you
might have like a terabyte of data right
and so it's so expensive to scan through
a terabyte of day they're just reading
it from disk right it's so expensive
that you would probably never even run
one iteration about you in the sense and
it turns out the the the this one one
huge saving graces to consecrate
understands is let's say runs the costly
grained descent right and you know you
end up with this parameter and that's
the parameter you use for your machine
learning system rather than the global
optimum it turns out that parameter is
actually not that bad right you you
probably make perfectly fine predictions
even if you don't get to like the global
global minimum so what you said I think
is a fine thing to do no harm trying it
although in practice in practice we
don't bother I think in practice we use
the customer in the same the thing that
actually is more common is to slowly
decrease the learning rate so just keep
using so-called green descent but reduce
the learning rate
time so it takes smaller and smaller
steps so if you do that then what
happens is the size of the oscillations
of decrease and so you end up
oscillating or bouncing around the
smaller regions so wherever you end up
may not be the global global minimum but
at least it'll be it'll be closer to the
yeah so the appeasing learning rate is
used much more often cool oh sure when
do you start with certain ranges and
plot to J of theta over a time so J of
theta is the cost function that you're
trying to drive down so monitor J of
theta as you know it's going down over
time and then if it looks like this stop
going down then you can say oh it looks
like a spout going down when it's not
raining oh and you know one nice thing
about linear regression is it has no
local optimum and so if you run into
these conversions debugging in terms of
issues less often when you're training
highly nonlinear things like neural
networks which talk about later in CST
tonight as well
oh these issues become more acute okay
great so um
Oh which I learn here if you want to
rent times linear expressions and not
really it's usually much bigger than
that
yeah yeah because if your learning rate
was 1 over n times that of Y should use
the fashion in descent then it ended up
being as slow as factual innocence so
there's usually much bigger okay so um
so that's the classic greater sin oh and
and so I'll tell you what I do if you
have a relatively small dataset you know
if you have if yep I don't know like a
hundreds of examples maybe a thousands
of examples where it's computationally
efficient to do batch gradient descent
if battery and descent doesn't cost too
much I would almost always just use
battery and descent because it's one
less thing to fiddle with right it's
just one less thing to have to worry
about the parameters oscillating but
your data said is too large that battery
understand becomes prohibitively slow
then almost everyone would use you know
so costly Granger sentence there right
Oh however more like so cost for any
sense
all right so gradient descents both
master and descent as so costly green
descent is an iterative algorithm
meaning that you have to take multiple
steps to get to you know get near
hopefully the global optimum it turns
out this is another algorithm oh and and
for many other algorithms we'll talk
about in this class including general
linear models and neural networks and a
few other algorithms you will have to
use gradient descent and so and so we'll
see gradient descent you know as we
develop multiple different algorithms
later this quarter it turns out that for
the special case of linear regression
and I mean linear regression but not the
other and we'll talk about next Monday
not the r1 with help on the expensive
but if the algorithm you're using is
linear regression of exactly linear
regression it turns out that there's a
way to solve for the optimal value of
the parameters theta to just jump in one
step to the global optimum without
needing to use an iterative algorithm
right and this this one I'm gonna
present makes is called the normal
equation it works only for linear
regression doesn't work for any of the
other arrows talked about me to the
school sir
but but let me quickly show you the
derivation of that and what I want to do
is give you a flavor of how to derive
the normal equation and where you end up
with is you know what what I hope to do
is end up with a formula that lets you
say theta equals some stuff where you
just set theta equals to that and in one
step with a few matrix multiplications
you end up with the optimal value of
theta that lands you right at the global
optimum right now just like that just in
one step okay um and if you've taken you
know advanced linear algebra classes
before something you may have seen
in this formula for linear regression
what what what the longer than Yashiro
clauses do is what some of the natural
classes do is cover the board with you
know pages and pages and matrix
derivatives what I want to do is
describe to you a matrix derivative
notation that allows you to derive the
normal equation in roughly four lines of
linear algebra rather than so pages and
pages in linear algebra and in the work
I've done in machine learning
you know sometimes notation really
matters right if you're the right
notation you can solve some problems
much more easily and what I want to do
is define this matrix linear algebra
notation and then I don't want to do all
the steps of the derivation I'm gonna
give you a give you a sense of the
flavor of what it looks like and then
I'll ask you to get a lot of details
yourself in the in the lecture notes
will work out everything in more detail
than I want to do algebra in class oh
and um in problem set one you get to
practice using this yourself - you know
derive some additional things that I
found this notation really convenient
right for deriving learning algorithms
okay so I'm going to use the following
notation so J right there's a function
mapping from parameters to the real
numbers so I'm going to define this this
is the derivative of J of theta with
respect to theta where remember a theta
is a three-dimensional vector so it's r3
Rashi's are n plus 1 right if you have
two features of the house if N equals 2
then theta is three-dimensional n plus 1
dimensional so it's a vector and so I'm
going to define the derivative with
respect to theta of J of theta as
follows
this is going to be yourself 3 by 1
vector
so hope this notation is clear so this
is a three-dimensional vector with three
components all right so that's why so
that's the first component is vector
that's the second and the third okay
it's a partial derivative J respecting
each of the three elements and more
generally in the notation we'll use
maybe an example um let's say that E is
a matrix so let's say that's a a is the
2 by 2 matrix then you can have a
function right so let's say a is you
know a11 a12 a21 a.22 right so a is a 2
by 2 matrix then you might have some
function of a matrix a right then that's
a real number so I'm gonna be F max from
a 2 by 2 - excuse me are 2 by 2
it's a real number so and so for example
if F of a equals a 1 1 plus a 1 2
squared then f of you know 5 6 7 8 would
be equal to I guess 5 plus 6 squared
right so as we derived this will be
working a little bit with functions that
map from matrices to real numbers and
this is just one made-up example of a
function that impose a matrix and maps
the matrix massive values of a matrix
serial number
and when you have a matrix function like
this I'm going to define the derivative
we respected a of F of a to be equal to
itself a matrix where the derivative of
f of a with respect to the matrix a this
itself will be a matrix with the same
dimension of a and the elements of this
are the derivative with respect to the
individual elements I'm just ready to
like this
okay so if a was a 2x2 matrix then the
derivative of F of a respect to a is
itself a two by two matrix and you
compute this two-by-two matrix just by
looking at F and taking derivatives with
respect to the different elements and
plugging them into the different the
different elements of this matrix okay
and so in this example I guess the
derivative respect to any of F of a this
would be right it would be over that and
I got these four numbers by taking the
definition of F and taking the
derivative with respect to a 1 1 and
plugging that here taking the respect to
a 1 2 and plugging that here and taking
the derivative respect to the remaining
elements and plugging them here so
that's the definition of a matrix they
remember - yeah
oh yes we do same definition for a
vector and by 1 or n by 1 matrix yes and
in fact that definition and dis
definition for the the reserving J
respective thing so these are consistent
so if you apply that definition to a
column vector treating a column vector
as an N by 1 matrix or input and it has
to be n plus 1 by 1 matrix then that
that specializes to what we described
here
all right so let's see so um I want to
leave the details to lecture notes
because there is more lines of algebra
but I want to but he'll give you an
overview of what the derivation of the
normal equation looks like so arms of
this definition of a derivative of a
matrix the broad outline that what we're
going to do is we're going to take J of
theta alright that's the cost function
take the derivative with respect to
theta right since theta is a vector so
you want to take derivatives with
respect to theta and you know well how
do you minimize the function you take
the Reuters respective theta and set it
equal to zero and then you solve for the
value of theta so that the derivative is
zero right the minimum you know the
maximum minimum function is whether
there is equal to zero so so how you
derive the normal equation is take this
vector so J of theta maps from a vector
to a real number so we'll take
derivatives with respect to theta set
that there is equal zero and solve for
theta and then we end up with a formula
for theta that lets you just you know
immediately go to the global minimum of
the cost function J of theta and and and
all of the build up and all of this
notation is you know is there what does
this mean and is there an easy way to
compute the derivative of J of theta
okay so to help you understand the
lecture notes when hopefully you take a
look at them just a couple other
derivation if a is a square matrix so
let's say a is a an N by n matrix so
number of rows equals number of columns
I'm going to denote the trace of a to be
equal to the sum of the diagonal entries
so some of our III and this is
pronounced the trace of a and and and
you know you can you can also write this
as trace operator like the trace
function applied to a but by convention
we often write trace of a without the
parentheses and so this is called a
trace so trace just means sum of
diagonal entries and some facts about
the trace of a matrix you know trace of
a is equal to the trace of a transpose
because if you transpose the matrix
right you're just flipping along the 45
degree axis and so the diagonal entries
actually stay the same when you
transpose the matrix so that trace of a
is equal to trace of a transpose and
then there there there are some other
useful properties of the trace operator
here's one that I don't want to prove
but that you could go home and prove
yourself with a few some little bit of
work maybe not not too much which is if
you define F of a equals trace of a
times B so here it B is some fixed
matrix right and what F of a does is it
multiplies a and B and then it takes to
sum of diagonal entries then it turns
out that the derivative with respect to
a of F of a is equal to B transpose and
this is you could prove this yourself
for any matrix B if F of a is defined
this way the derivative is equal to B
transpose the trace function or the
trace operator has other interesting
properties the trace of a B is equal to
the trace of B a you could prove this
from principle it's a little bit of work
to prove that you if you expand out the
definitions a and B sure
that and the tracer a times B times C is
equal to you the trace of C times a
times B this is a cyclic permutation
property if you ever multiple you know
multiply several matrices together you
can always take one from the end and
move it to the front and the trace will
remain the same and another one that is
a little bit harder to prove is that the
trace
excuse me derivative of eight runs a
transpose C is okay so I think just as
just as for your ordinary calculus we
know the derivative of x squared is 2x
right and so we all figured out that
grew and we just use it too much without
without having to read arrive every time
this is a little bit like that the trace
of a squared C is you know two times C a
right it's an open like that with matrix
notation that's there so think of this
as analogous to DDA of a squared C
equals to AC but this is like the matrix
version of that
all right so finally what I'd like to do
is take J of theta and express it in
this you know matrix vector notation so
we can take the Reuters respect to theta
and set those equal to zero and just
solve for the value of theta right and
so let me just write out the definition
of J of theta so J of theta it was 1/2
something I equals 1 cm squared and it
turns out that
it turns out that some if you did if you
define the matrix capital X as follows
which is I'm going to take the matrix
capital X and take the training examples
we have you know and stack them up in
rows so we have M training examples
right so so the XS will call them
vectors so I'm taking transpose you just
stack up to K examples in n rows here so
let me call this the design matrix but
couple X color design matrix and it
turns out that if you define X this way
then x times theta is this thing times
theta and the way of matrix vector
multiplication works is your theta is
now a column vector right so theta is
you know theta 0 theta 1 theta 2 so the
way that matrix vector multiplication
works is you multiply this column vector
with each of these in intern and so this
ends up being X 1 transpose theta X 2
transpose theta down to X M transpose
theta which is of course just a vector
of all of the predictions of the
algorithm
and so if now let me also define a
vector Y to be taking all of the labels
from your training example and stacking
them up into a big column vector right
let me define Y that way it turns out
that J of theta can then be written as
1/2 X theta minus y transpose X theta
minus y ok and let me just outline the
proof but I won't do this in great
detail so X theta minus y is going to be
right so this is X later this is y so
you know X theta minus y it's going to
be this vector of H of X 1 minus y 1
down to H of X M minus y M right this is
just all the errors your learning
algorithm is making on the examples the
difference between predictions and the
actual labels and if you remember so Z
transpose Z is equal to sum over I Z
squared like a vector transpose itself
is the sum of squares of elements and so
this vector transpose itself is the sum
of squares of the elements right so so
which is y so the cost function J of
theta is computed by taking the sum of
squares of all of these elements of all
of these errors and the way you do that
is to take this vector you know X a the
minus y transpose itself is the sum of
squares of the
which is exactly the era so that's why
you end up with this is the sum of
squares of the those error terms okay
and um if some of the steps don't quite
make sense really don't worry about it
all this is written out more slowly and
carefully in the lecture notes but I
wanted you to have a sense of the
brought off of the of the big picture of
the derivation before you go through
them yourself and great disease on the
lecture notes elsewhere
so finally what we want to do is take
the derivative respect the theta of jr.
theta and set that to zero and so this
is going to be equal to the derivative
of 1/2 X theta minus y transpose X Y and
so I'm gonna I'm gonna do the steps
really quickly right so the steps
require some of the little properties of
traces and matrix derivatives that wrote
down briefly just now but so I'm gonna
do these very quickly without going into
the details better
so this is equal to 1/2 there's our
theta of so take transposes of these
things so this becomes theta transpose X
transpose minus y transpose and then
kind of like expanding out a quadratic
function right this is you know a minus
B times C minus D as you can this is AC
minus 80 and so on since so I just write
this out
and so what I just did here this is
similar to how you know ax minus B times
ax minus B is equal to a squared x
squared minus ax b minus b ax ax plus b
squared it's kind of it's just expanding
out the quadratic function
and then the final step is is that right
oh yes thank you um and then the final
step is you know for each of these four
terms first second third and fourth
terms to take the derivative with
respect to theta and if you use some of
the formulas I was alluding to over
there you find that the derivative which
which I don't want to show the
derivation out but it turns out that the
derivative is X transpose X theta plus X
transpose X theta minus X transpose Y
minus X transpose Y and we're going to
set this derivative and so the
simplifies to X transpose X theta minus
X transpose Y and so as described where
they are gonna set this derivative to
zero but how they go from this step to
that step is using the matrix
derivatives explained in more detail in
the lecture notes and so the final step
is you know having said this a zero this
implies that X transpose X theta equals
X transpose Y so this is called the
normal equations and the optimum value
for theta is theta equals x transpose x
inverse X transpose Y okay
and if you implement this then you know
you can in basically one step get the
value of theta that corresponds the
global minimum and and and again common
question I get is - well what if x is
non-invertible what that usually means
is you have redundant features that your
features are linearly dependent
but if you use something called the
pseudo-inverse you you kind of get the
right answer if that's the case although
I think that even more right answers if
you have linear dependent features
probably means you have the same feature
repeated twice and I would usually go
and figure out what features actually
repeated leading to this problem okay
all right any last questions before so
that so that's a normal equations hope
you read through the detailed
derivations in lecture notes any last
questions going great
oh yeah how do you choose salon area
it's this is quite empirical I think so
most people would try different values
and just pick one all right I think
let's let's break if people have more
questions where the tears come up we can
acute Aten questions were less grateful
today thanks everyone